this was the greatest football game ever
played do you believe you've ever seen
it is the greatest highschool football
game of all time even twenty years later
that's still the greatest game and the
greatest ending I've ever seen in my
life in football this game made it
possible that the game is never ever
over Texas high school football
tradition you know it's goes right below
church where I blow God and that's the
truth the team in 94 was my first year
to be at Plano East there was just a
great group of athletes and put together
they reeled off 12 straight victories
through some really good football teams
we were a rough squad man we knew when
we stepped on that field that nobody had
a chance 94 Panthers I'll put that squad
up against anybody else you've got to
win six playoff games to win the state
championship and we were in Game three
that's the holy grail of Texas football
Texas Stadium John Tyler was the real
deal
well I knew they were fast and they were
an absolute track team it was one of
those David and Goliath like deals
almost they were extremely talented
whoever won that football game was the
team that was going to win the state
championship before everything broke
loose
it was a great high school game the
first three quarters were an absolute
battle between two great teams even
midway through the fourth quarter we're
on the 10-yard line going in to score
Jeff Whitley cuts it up now he is caught
by broad groans nobody will catch him
holy cow touchdown that started the
landslide when that happened people just
started filing out of Texas Stadium I
felt like I lost the game we lost
another one on the weird play whit goes
back to pass he's blindsided by David
Warner ends up playing at Florida
State's all-american Florida State
sophomore at the time he he blindsides
he picks up the ball goes in for another
touchdown so that quick the game got out
of here they recovered another fumble
and went for another touchdown bingo
bango bongo I honestly had tears in my
eyes and news my high school career was
over two touchdowns scored by them and
you know 30 seconds to a minute it's
because of you you have a lot of regret
about that with three minutes and three
seconds to go in the game we're down 41
to 17 I wasn't motivate many people and
we go into our this has been a great
season for Plano he's 253 left to go in
the ball game and then all heck broke
loose
Kevin Court broke the trap and went all
the way down to about the 25-yard line
next play Whitley dropped back and hit
Terrence green on a post route for a
touchdown we go for two and don't make
it it's 40 123 then here it came the
comeback was unreal I felt like
literally I was in a movie onside hey
baby they're not quitting this is really
good I mean we still far as like doing
an onside kick yes I was the first time
that I've done that and executed it in a
game we got the first onside kick went
out there scored again
Whitley and now with a minute 50 it's 41
31 so now we have a belief that hey this
could be possible we hit him any fumble
the ball we got it another onside kick
and it's just like wow
- we need six right here baby we in this
rash move left free pass I'm in Superman
mode it's not one person is going to
tackle parents brain is Superman then
let's go forty one thirty seven we
kicked the third onside kick it's the
perfect kick and the improbable happen
three times gonna have them in
we believed we were going to win the
game at that point he was wide open the
greatest feeling that I've ever had in
sports and I just remember looking at
the crowd and my thought was I've never
seen a crowd go back crazy everybody on
their cars in the radio back to play no
I don't we kicked the extra point went
ahead 44 to 41 it was an amazing time
you just thought you know this is a
miracle gods have been good to me 24
seconds left in the game kick it off
tackle them a couple of incomplete
passes one more game first state
championship for playing at least I
don't have three times in a row there
are scared parents three it's gonna kick
the ball back over their head a lot of
emotions running I think I even had
tears thinking like wow we did it when
nobody thought that we could we could do
no wrong until the last kickoff I put my
hand up I remember doing this and
putting it down for that last time
letting them know that I was fixing to
kick this ball deep where's the kickoff
24 seconds left Terrence green boots it
high and deep seconds rubbery got across
oh my gosh
I don't I'm sick I want to throw up
everybody was crying I was included was
it a mistake that we kicked a deep I
don't think so
it just wasn't meant for us I can
remember the ride home on the bus it was
just dead quiet to actually go down like
that it was just sad there's such Pig we
talked about it yeah
god bless those kids
you never stop until that final whistle
blows people recognize your or they know
that you played in that game and you had
a significant part that will definitely
stick with me forever
when you get a group of guys that
believe in each other and believe in a
sole purpose and have good leadership
like we had anything's possible
it's a great product for a coach to show
his team whether it be a baseball team
or a football team or a basketball team
of why you never quit why you never give
up this is the most famous game ever
played in Texas high school football but
I never thought I would be famous for
losing
you